for years now the libs have claimed that
the Maga movement is a fringe political
phenomenon that it does not represent
the mainstream of American politics that
it doesn't even represent the mainstream
of the Republican Party despite Donald
Trump's winning the nomination twice and
the presidency at least once they claim
that even if Trump did win the
presidency he didn't win the popular
vote his views are minority views and
very few people really like him at all
which is pretty rich coming from
Democrats since as usual pretty much
every accusation that they hurl at Trump
and the conservatives and all of us
applies much more clearly to themselves
a new poll from ABC News and the
Washington Post not exactly right-wing
Outlets shows that just 35 percent of
Democrats and democrat-leaning
Independence want Joe Biden to be the
Democrat nominee for president in 2024.
that's not 35 percent of Americans which
would be pretty astounding even in and
of itself
we're talking about 35 percent
of Democrats
who think that this guy should be
president obviously it's a much lower
percentage of Americans overall who
think that the guy should be in the Oval
Office
the most basic takeaway from this poll
is that for all their Praise of our
sacred democracy the Democrats actually
don't care all that much about our
alleged democracy and are more than
happy to impose their radical views and
agenda on the majority of people that
rejects them
but the more important takeaway
is a lesson that radical leftists
learned a long time ago a lesson that
conservatives seem to forget
political movements don't need majority
support to get things done to be
successful in fact virtually every
significant political movement in
history has been brought about not by
the majority but by distinct minorities
from the Jacobins to the Bolsheviks to
the radical Elites of our own times who
despite constantly ignoring the will of
the people on pretty much every issue on
immigration on industry on foreign
policy on obviously the weird sex stuff
on everything in between nevertheless
always
seem to find themselves entrenched in
power
and we conservatives can mock them
or we can complain or we can shout our
frustration from the rooftops
but maybe the better strategy would be
to learn from them
and maybe just maybe take a little bit
of power back ourselves I'm Michael
Knowles it's the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Laura's heart
who says very proud to be Italian right
now funny how nobody on the left will
congratulate Georgia Maloney for being
the first woman prime minister in Italy
oh well of course she's not a woman
she's not a woman she would only be a
woman if she were a liberal politician
but she's a conservative politician a
successful conservative politician and a
conservative politician who is
successful who was talking about things
that actually matter not just stupid
marginal tax rates but immigration Life
Family culture tradition all the stuff
that actually matters to people and so
the libs write her off I remember I was
I was running a great blog when I was I
think it was my senior year of college a
pal and I started it which was we would
just post actual quotes from gender
studies departments and like like
published gender studies papers we would
just post quotes of them and that was
the whole blog and one of them was a
quote from a published work of gender
studies which said that Sarah Palin is
not a woman because she is conservative
by being conservative she relinquished
her Womanhood what is a woman I don't
know people have been asking that
question I guess for a very very long
time I do know that if you're a man
you're going to remain until the end of
your life if you're a woman you're going
to remain a woman until the end of your
life there's nothing you can do to
change it
and speaking of the end of your life you
got to check out epic will right now
head on over to epicwill.com use promo
code Knowles you know what I just had to
do I had to update my will I've had a
will since I was 18 and I had to update
my will because I just had my sweet
little Second Son so you got to make
sure that this is all up to date because
I care about what happens to my stuff I
care about what happens to my money but
more than that I care about what happens
to my kids and your will it's important
to get all of your assets locked away
and and tell people where those should
go when you finally kick it but you
especially want to know what's going to
happen with your kids and your family
right now just take the time head on
over to Epic will and protect everything
that's going to happen to your kingdom
all the stuff that matters to you after
you die we're talking about your last
will your living will your health care
power of attorney the list goes on and
on and on right now it's just 119 bucks
you can get a will and especially when
you use promo code Knowles you can save
10 percent on Epic Wills complete will
package that is epicwill.com promo code
Knowles the Democrats obviously are
are catering to a very radical minority
of the American people right now on all
the big issues that they're pushing on
immigration
um really even the structure of our
society on certainly this weird sex
stuff and the drag queen Story Hour and
the gender bathrooms and all that crap
the Democrats are not speaking as the
voice of the majority of the American
people they're speaking to a very very
Fringe minority all the while they're
ignoring mainstream bread and butter
issues and not even just the issues that
conservatives care about in the rural
parts of the middle of the country we're
talking about regular old
urgent issues that even liberals living
in cities care about issues like crime
Kareen Jean-Pierre the president's
spokesman was just asked does Joe Biden
believe that today in Biden's America
America's big cities are safe Karine
Jean-Pierre pretended not even to
understand the question
this President Biden think America's big
cities are safe
can you say more well we know that
deaths and robberies are up about 20 in
the first half of this here so I'm
wondering if he thinks America's big
cities are safe are you talking about
the New York Times story and
specifically or is that what you're
referring to the murder rate still 30
above its 2019 level they're all from
the Council on criminal justice so we've
seen some high profile examples of this
the Washington Commander's running back
was being mugged he got shot uh Karen
bass member of Congress had her house
robbed these are high profile people so
should
everyday Americans who are not in the
public eye feel safe so I'll say this
that same story also stated that the
crime is complicated and multifaceted uh
look this is a president who has secured
historic funding to make sure that law
enforcement has what its needs
especially and he was able to do this in
the face of opposition from Republicans
so her first reaction is to pretend like
she doesn't understand the question very
simple question by the way are the
Cities Safe
um I'm sorry you're going to need to
what what do you mean it depends on what
the definition of city is what what do
you mean by safe I mean like I won't get
shot
um I don't are you referring to a news
story I'm referring to a simple question
are the Cities Safe well look it's
complicated crime is really complicated
like sometimes they want to steal your
watch but other times they want to steal
your purse so and sometimes they stab
you and other times they shoot you so
it's really complicated and I don't it's
just like we can't oversimplify
by and so first she pretends not to
understand the question then she does
that thing that all the libs do and they
always do this in Academia especially
they just say it's well we've got we've
got to complicate it we've got to
problematize it's really nothing's
really simple anymore and then then she
denies it right then she says well it
doesn't make any sense because Joe Biden
has all these great policies that are
supposed to fix crime
right and then but the obvious answer to
that is right but they're not doing that
they're not fixing crime no no but Peter
you don't understand he secured a lot of
money to fix the crime for his policies
right
I know there would seem to be a
disagreement between
the theory that you guys are pushing
and the reality the the consequences of
your policies in the real world
and when there is a disagreement
between reality and Theory what normal
sane people do is they throw out the
theory
what Democrats do is they throw out the
reality and they this has been a
consistent pattern specifically from
Green jumpier and she's just the
mouthpiece for the White House so it's
the pattern from the white houses they
just deny that it's happening
we're in a recession oh no we're not
what do you mean we're not we've had two
consecutive quarters of negative GDP
growth no
no that's not what a recession is
anymore
no we're not in that anymore
we've got record high inflation
no we don't
what are you talking about we don't have
inflation the goods now cost eight and a
half percent at least above what they
did last year yeah no but that's not how
we're going to measure inflation anymore
now we're just going to go month to
month
and it's actually still up a little bit
month to month but it's not it's no no
never mind nothing to see here what
about all the crime people are getting
robbed and stabbed and killed and no
no Biden secured funding these are not
the droids you're looking for pay no
attention so for issues that really
matter to people I'm not talking about
those of us who think about politics a
lot and those of us who have maybe a
little more of a systematic view of the
way politics ought to work and a view of
the world which if you were listening to
this show I'm not flattering you just
but it is simply a fact if you were
listening to this show you are very
plugged into politics you think about
these things you have you have a certain
Viewpoint you have a way that you want
the world to look and for most people
probably they don't spend all that time
on that maybe they're spending their
time thinking about other things they're
they're not political nerds reading all
the latest reports and watching the
latest press conferences
and and for those people
the important political issues are are
not
industrial policy the hot though the you
know abstract sort of industrial policy
it's not uh even abortion a lot of us
care a lot a lot about abortion for for
most people they don't pay that much
attention to it it's not a top priority
but I promise you one of the top
priorities
safety
[Music]
can I walk outside
can I is my is my family is my property
going to be safe
my home my car these things going to be
safe
and the White House says we ignore that
who cares
we don't care about any of that stuff
okay to say nothing of then when you get
to the more ideological questions what
is a man what is a woman what is human
life are we going to kill babies are we
going to let men go into the little
girl's room are we going to sell away
our sovereignty to transnational
organizations are we going to let woke
corporations that are being pressured by
the Biden Administration be the kind of
enforcement mechanism for the the sorts
of things that the Biden Administration
wants to do that they're not legally
permitted to do like censor their
opponents in the Public Square all of
those questions the libs are totally
the aggressors here okay and they're out
of step with the American tradition and
they are really ramping up some pretty
radical policies okay but even on the
bread and butter normal stuff can you
leave your home even on that they're
completely failing and so when I look at
that situation I look at Biden's poll
numbers and I look at the just absolute
dismal state of the country on pretty
much every metric I think there is no
way that a normal person could support
these people
and the numbers back me up normal people
are not supporting these people the ones
who are supporting Biden right now are
the radicals
and the in in enshrined established
powers that be and specifically a subset
of that group
the squish Republicans I'm talking about
people like Adam kinsiger I'm talking
about people like Liz Cheney people that
we really really should have booted out
of our political movement a long time
ago and when you want to replace people
who are in your organization and get the
best people possible to to do the job
you obviously got to check out
ZipRecruiter right now head on over to
zippercrater.com Knowles did you know
that there are currently over 2.4
million podcasts in the world including
the one you're listening to right now
that's crazy that's a huge number takes
a team of people to bring those podcasts
together
we got the audio Engineers we've got the
editors we've got my associate producers
I love them and we've got we've got Ben
Davies the producer for now I don't know
thankfully there's ziprecruiter.com we
can figure out what we need okay hiring
the right people for these roles is
important and whether you're hiring for
a podcast or for your growing business
there's only one place that makes it
easy sip recruiter now you can try it
for free at ziprecruiter.com Knowles
easily review your recommended
candidates invite your top choices to
apply zip recruiter's got a complete
Suite of tools makes it super easy to
filter review and rate your candidates
four out of five employers who post on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day if you want to try
supercruiter for free today you need to
remember this special URL
ziprecruiter.com that's ziprecruiter.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s ZipRecruiter the smartest
way to hire
Liz Cheney
has a threat
she's saying
that if Donald Trump is the nominee
in 2024 for the Republicans she
she might leave the Republican Party
I think that Donald Trump is he's the
only president in American history who
refused to guarantee a peaceful
transition to power and so
um now the fact that my party has
refused
in the months since then to stand up to
him I think does tell you how sick the
party is I'm gonna make sure Donald
Trump I mean everything I can't make
sure he's not the nominee and if he is a
nominee I won't be a Republican
okay
thank you
Liz Cheney out of the Republican party
don't threaten me with a good time
Liz Cheney of course is not a republican
she might pretend to be a republican she
might when she goes on to all of the
Democrat news networks to attack the
Republicans she might put an R next to
her name and but she was first of all
she was kicked out of her own State
party the Wyoming Republican party
booted her out but let's say she she
identifies as a republican for practical
purposes she is not a Republican
and why not I don't want to play
psychobabble I don't want to say it's
because of her Pride I don't want to say
it's because she got Trump derangement
syndrome because Donald Trump attacked
her and attacked her father and some of
the administrations she worked for I I'm
I don't know why Liz Cheney is doing
this but it simply a fact she is for all
intents and purposes a Democrat she
voted for Joe Biden last time and that's
simply unacceptable that's not we talked
about this a little bit yesterday on the
show
Joe Biden sent his Jack booted Thug FBI
agents to the home of a pro-life author
and Advocate a man who peacefully
demonstrates outside of abortion clinics
and he sent these jack-booted FBI thugs
to point their rifles at this man and
his family and his seven children and
terrorize the family and it's just it's
it's just the latest
acceleration of an attack by the Biden
Administration on Christians on
conservatives on pro-lifers in
particular the Biden Administration
which
describes parents who don't want their
kids to be taught critical race Theory
and weird sex stuff in school as a
domestic extremist threat basically
calling these people terrorists the
Biden Administration don't forget Joe
Biden back in the Obama Administration
that Administration sued nuns because
the nuns didn't want to kill little
babies and go along with the left's
radical sexual Revolution agenda Joe
Biden who refers to half the country
refers to you as fast semi-fashion
chests and extreme threats to our
democracy Joe Biden who is hiring up 87
000 IRS agents to attack you Joe Biden
who time and time again
is attacking conservatives now imposing
abortion despite the Court's ruling in
Dobbs imposing abortion in in pro-life
States okay it is not acceptable Joe
Biden who is now imposing
child transgenderism
through his Federal bureaucracy
castrating little kids Joe Biden who's
hiring overt satanists guys who actually
have pentagrams on their chest okay it's
not acceptable to defend this stuff to
say nothing of the lawlessness the open
borders that the
the attacks on pretty much every
American way of life it's not defensible
I don't want a hero oh Liz Cheney she's
just got a different point of view oh
well you know it's sort of reasonable
reasonable Minds can disagree sure but
reasonable Minds cannot support Joe
Biden okay Joe Biden says we're in a war
for the soul of our nation and he allies
himself with with actual satanists and
actively promotes castrating little kids
and putting them on Gross sex hormones
and killing a bunch of other little kids
and and keeping the Border open and
flooding the country with foreigners and
suppressing our political rights and
censoring us and and throwing grannies
who showed up to the Capitol Rotana and
into into solitary confinement meanwhile
encouraging BLM and antifa to Riot and
kill people I just don't want to hear it
I just don't want to hear it yeah we are
in a soul a battle for the soul of our
nation
and you've got to pick a side there is
no neutrality there is no reasonable
Minds disagree here okay and Liz Cheney
has said and and this the squishes that
she stands for there aren't very many of
them but some people
are saying yeah I'll vote for Joe Biden
when the going gets tough
okay fine but then you're not you know
you're not a republican it's not
reasonable and I have absolutely no
respect for the woman
it's just like we were talking about
those FBI agents yesterday I tried to
distinguish between the good the good
FBI agents who do good work and who
sometimes have to follow bad orders and
the corrupt Biden officials who are
running the FBI in the doj but sometimes
you can't let the the agents off the
hook and when those agents got the call
to go raid the home of the pro-lifer and
his and his wife and his seven kids for
no reason
uh then I don't let those agents off the
hook I I hold them personally morally
responsible for what they're doing okay
and I think that they're they should be
greatly ashamed and they should
apologize and they should resign and
they should refuse the order
and I don't want to hear oh well you
know it was a very confusing time it's
very complicated like green jean-pierces
it's not that complicated
but Ronald Reagan said that the path
forward sometimes is simple not easy
necessarily but simple that there's
really no difference between a left and
a right only an up or a down well pick a
side pick a side
you want to see what they're doing
in Chattanooga Tennessee
Chattanooga Tennessee that's supposed to
be a right-wing place they just held a
youth
gay pride event
these are words that should not go in
the same sentence ever
they hold a youth gay pride event at
which a little girl
was was massaging stroking the the groin
of one of the performers I don't even
know if the performer was a man or a
woman
clip by way of Robbie Starbuck
we've blurred out the girl's face and
it's really horrifying but you can still
make it out a little bit blurry she's
just stroking
this person's pelvis I don't know if
it's a man I don't know if it's a woman
he's he or she is dressed up in a
mermaid costume then you've got some
other pervert jumps out in drag wearing
a tiny little mini skirt lifts his leg
up for it to a tiny little kid
then you got another one walking around
with this one is clearly a dude dressed
up in Drag
shaking his exposed derriere to what
looks like I don't know an eight or nine
year old boy
that's happening in Chattanooga
Tennessee
so if you vote for the Democrats if you
vote for the libs you're voting for this
stuff and that's a lot different than
well I think we should have slightly
more immigration well I think we should
maybe raise tax rates on corporations a
little bit that is this is some sick
demonic stuff and if you vote for these
people you are supporting this and I I
think
I think you're going to be held morally
accountable for this
okay in in this life in the life of the
world to come more importantly I just
it's not good for your soul it's not
good for the country there's no reason
to support these people I I have to ask
myself why is this happening in the
middle of the country
you actually don't see stuff this crazy
in San Francisco
or in New York City you see plenty of
crazy stuff out there but you you would
expect to see crazier things in San
Francisco and New York and Chicago and
wherever but you don't it's it's these
weird towns in Iowa or Mississippi or
now Chattanooga where you're seeing the
craziest version of this stuff little
kids actually stroking the genitals of
these drag pervert performers
to a bunch of clapping seals who are who
are their their parents who should have
their kids taken away from them and and
the other adults in the room
why I think that shows you the power of
this kind of cultural imperialism that
you're seeing from the libs especially
in the coastal cities because
the libs in the coastal cities
no matter what they preach
they do tend to want nice things they
tend to be richer they tend to be more
established and they they want to keep
their own kind of
semi-civilized way of life going on but
they preach all this crap to everybody
and then it's it's very often in the
smaller towns that are not as I don't
know immune to the craziest predations
of this radical culture that's where you
see it really explode
where there's there are no guard rails
whatsoever and it goes completely off
the rails but but we would be fooling
ourselves if we say well that's San
Francisco for you that's why okay that's
why I'm I'm in a good old red State like
Tennessee yeah Tennessee is I I'm
breathing much Freer air here in
Tennessee but this crap is coming to
Tennessee and it's coming to Iowa and
it's coming to Mississippi and it's
coming to it's coming to a red State
near you in a red town near you okay
so it's really really a big problem
and we are not going to solve it by
burying our heads in the sand what are
we supposed to do about it well if you
think that that is the end of the line
if you think that that's the bottom of
the slippery slope I got another thing
for you pink news
which is not a satire website it's not a
homophobic website it's an LGBT website
they have a headline why can't gay or
lesbian twins have sex with or marry
each other why is incest wrong between
same-sex siblings and I know the first
reaction to this is going to be one of
absolute revulsion
and then a kind of mockery from from
people on the left the people on the
left who didn't write this and who
aren't running think news
because clearly those leftists are
taking it seriously but some people the
kind of moderate Libs you're gonna say
oh come on come on that's a slippery
slope argument
right like all of the all of the correct
arguments about this weird sex stuff
come on that's a slippery slope argument
come on we all know why it's wrong okay
then here's my challenge to you
tell me why it's wrong given the
premises on marriage on sex on
individual liberties or whatever that
we've all accepted in our modern
American way of life tell me why it is
wrong for gay or lesbian twins
siblings who they're not at risk of
procreation not at risk of creating a
child who's you know at higher risk for
certain abnormalities and therefore you
might make some some argument well the
child didn't consent or whatever kind of
lame moral arguments the modern Libs
make
tell me there's no risk of having a kid
why is that why is incest between gay
siblings wrong
if you if you can't explain it
then you I think you've got a very bad
case of liberal modernity
pink news wants to know why can't gay or
lesbian twins have sex with or marry
each other well
the reason is because to quote the Great
bioethicist
and philosopher and theologian Norm
Macdonald sex is a filthy shameful thing
that's obviously only meant for
procreation
which is not that answer from Norm is
actually about 85 percent right there's
a little more to it than that
but why well because sex is a very
powerful human thing and so we have this
um this institution which happens to be
the fundamental political institution
which is called marriage that actually
helps us to make sense of our sexual
desires and our sexual nature and
marriage is the union of one man and one
woman for the sake of the generation and
education of children and everyone
understood this until about five minutes
ago now that's all gone out the Wayside
and now we say What is marriage tell me
what marriage is
since 2015 since a distinct political
minority radically redefined marriage
against the will of the American people
kind of we're kind of like how a lot of
political movements take shape
regardless of their democratic
pretensions
when that happened then marriage became
the union of two people who love each
other regardless of their
sex
okay but my best friend and I we love
each other not that way but you know we
love each other so are we married no
we're not married because you have to I
guess you maybe you have to have sex to
be mayor but no you don't have to have
sex to be married
there's no requirement that you will
have I mean that traditionally you had
to consummate a marriage for it to be
considered a marriage but that we've
redefined marriage that's not in there
so what is it is it well
if sexual differencesn't at the heart of
marriage okay if
then what is marriage
if it's just about two people who get a
certain romantic pleasure from one
another then why can't the twins do it
took consenting adults right well my
answer the conservative answer is
because consent is not all that matters
there are some behaviors that are wrong
many behaviors that are wrong actually
that are that are remain wrong and ought
to be suppressed including by the heavy
hand of the state
even if the adults sort of consent to it
the relationship between a drug dealer
and a drug addict
that is a seemingly consensual sort of
relationship
even though addiction compromises our
ability to consent just like all sin
compromises our ability to consent
because the man who sins is enslaved to
sin but let's say that you got the
relationship between a drug dealer the
heroin dealer and the heroin addict
today at least for now at least in most
of America we say that that consensual
relationship
is is illegal they cannot do the thing
that the drug dealers and the drug users
do together because there's there is a
higher moral consideration than consent
and we used to understand this about sex
that's certainly one of the arguments
against incest
but if we can't do that if we're not
allowing ourselves to articulate moral
considerations that are deeper
and higher actually than mere consent
then we're totally sunk then we're
totally lost
we're we're starting to work our way
back there a little bit you're seeing
this in the fight over the the Pediatric
gender clinics
even though still it's that moral
argument is still focused on consent
right the argument is the kids can't
consent and the parents are consenting
on behalf of the kids but the parents
are extremely deranged if they're
willing to take their kids in to get
their body parts chopped off so that a
little boys can seem more like little
girls and so we're saying that there's
no real consent going on here we got to
shut it down there's great news
Tennessee lawmakers are now
looking at legislation to crack down on
the child gender transitions
this is in large part thanks to Matt
Walsh and Matt Walsh broke the story
personally and then it was thanks to a
lot of the research by the team here at
the daily wire that was able to do that
so now you're seeing some legislation to
to stop the kid gender clinics
I think we need to go further than that
though
and I floated this idea yesterday and
some people thought I was kidding I'm
not kidding because I think we need
gender clinics I actually think it's
good to have gender clinics
and right now what the gender clinics do
is they take
confused little boys who think that
they're little girls and then they mold
them sometimes surgically to look more
like little girls
and certainly psychologically they mold
them to seem more like little girls and
vice versa they take little confused
girls
and they mold them to seem more like
little boys
and that's not and that's horrible
the next best thing that we could do
would be to get rid of those gender
clinics but the really the best thing
that we would do is have gender clinics
that take confused little boys and mold
them to be more like little boys
and take confused little girls and mold
them to be more like little girls
so you might call the little girl one uh
the the beauty salon you know the the
hair styling place the mani pedi shop
that's what the doctor should do the
doctor should see the confused teenage
girl comes in says I think I'm a boy so
okay well you're obviously not a boy so
I'm going to write you a prescription
for one mani pedi here you go go to the
beauty salon and get your nails done oh
The Boy comes in
we used to have these kinds of gender
clinics you know the boy you'd be a
little confused I think I'm a girl no I
don't think you are I'm going to
prescribe you one uh year in Boy Scouts
yeah you're gonna go camping you know
and start a fire or maybe if it's an
older teenage boy you say I'm gonna
prescribe you two cigars at the local
cigar lounge talking to men about man
stuff
there you go I'm going to prescribe you
to three hours at the gym I kind of I
actually missed that particular gender
Clinic that was that was never my cup of
tea I more favored you know the other
one but
I mean this sincerely I know it sounds
like I'm joking and I'm it's it's a kind
of funny idea but I mean it sincerely
it's it's kind of like the Free Speech
issue
conservatives
used to understand free speech and then
we kind of lost our way for 20 years and
now we're starting to get it a little
bit again this is what my book
speechless was about
there's no such thing as neutrality
there's no such thing as we need free
speech for everybody and we should have
no taboos and no standards and nothing's
off limits at all that's never existed
in any society it's not possible
cultures and societies are defined by
our taboos and what's off limits and
what's held sacred and all the rest
so the question is not
Free Speech versus censorship it's what
the standards are and what what is it
going to be used to be that you could
teach the Bible in school you couldn't
teach porn in school now it's the
opposite right you can't teach the Bible
in school and they do teach porn in
school so we gotta we gotta fight over
those standards what's the same thing
here
there's no there's no neutrality when it
comes to gender in fact that's what the
libs want the libs want there to be a
neutrality where we're all just kind of
asexual gray blobs who are completely
androgynous and use whatever bathroom
there but no actually Human Nature
has is
has something intrinsically to do with
sexual difference the fact that there
are men and women in this world is one
of the most beautiful aspects of the
world
and Men
have an obligation to act like men even
if they don't want to even if they're
kind of confused and women have an
obligation to act like women
gender expression is real that's not
it's not made up it's real
and the men should act more masculine
and the women should act more feminine
speaking of women's issues a 19 year old
tick talker
has just gone viral because various sad
stories she just got a blood clot and
she got the blood clot from her hormonal
birth control take a listen
so she's got the text here on the on the
tick tock uh starts to get a slight
headache
she's in a hospital bed
takes Tylenol hoping it'll go away
headache doesn't go away turns into a
pounding migraine
and she takes Excedrin hoping the
migraine will go away
it seems like she's in good spirits as
she recovers
and then the migraine continues for days
starts sweating profusely starts to
vomit getting really really sick
Head Start Urgent Care
you have a cortisone shot
they say it's really just a bad migraine
but it's not just a bad migraine
then
then of course something works for a
little bit then she goes to the ER
because she's still got this horrible
pounding headache gets blood work and
MRIs turns out
just got a blood clot in the brain
because she's been taking birth control
for three years and that's what caused
him so you got to give credit to this
tick tocker because she turns even a
life-threatening horrifying experience
into great content just kind of dancing
in the little hospital bed and she seems
to be
you know indecent spirits that she
recovers
but she could have died easily could
have died from that
and then you got to ask yourself what
would she have died for
[Music]
she would have died
for the possibility of having
promiscuous sex
and I'm not even shaming her for this
young girls all over America are
pressured into taking hormonal birth
control it is like a given when even
when I was a when I was a wee lad not
that long ago when I was growing up all
the girls
in Suburban New York were put on birth
control from age 12 onward probably
their parents put them on it and
sometimes there'd be some excuse oh it
regulates their menstrual cycle or
something but it was really just to put
them on it so that when they did have
promiscuous sex they it wouldn't get
pregnant
that's what it was about for what
this woman almost died
for something that
really is only desired by men like I
know that women have convinced
themselves because of feminism that they
really want to have promiscuous sex with
lots of men but they don't men and women
relate to sex differently and men have
every every sort of natural drive to
have promiscuous sex with lots and lots
of women women don't really have that
women have different incentives and
because of the fact of pregnancy and
because of their biochemistry and
because of just what makes a woman a
woman
so you think why would she do this
they're obviously your side effects
you're not allowed to talk about that
you're not allowed to talk about the
side effects of birth control you're not
allowed to talk about the side effects
of the covet vaccines heaven for fend
you're not allowed to talk about any of
the side effects of our of our Public
Health establishment and all that kind
of crap that they pump us with
but it's all there and for what
this woman this young woman would be
much healthier and much happier if she
didn't take this stuff and it seems
radical today it seems radical today
to live in a way that people lived 50
years ago forget 50 even 30 40 years ago
it seems so radical that's how much the
libs these this radical minority of
people has shifted the Overton window
okay but it doesn't need to be this way
Young Girls teenage girls you don't you
don't need to give yourself blood clots
just to make men happy so that you can
maybe entice them to stay with you
beyond a one-night stand okay you don't
have to do that there is another option
there is a better way of life available
to us
do you like money specifically do you
like making companies money saving
companies money making other people save
money who would otherwise spend it have
we got a job for you daily wire has a
Nashville based opening for a Chief
Financial Officer the CFO will oversee
our accounting FP a and AD sales teams
eight to ten years of experience in
financial management is ideal prior
relevant experience within an
established Media or subscription-based
organization is required agility as a
leader is key the company is in hyper
growth mode and we constantly break and
rebuild things to successfully scale at
the rate that we do this sounds like you
head on over to dailywire.com careers to
apply
speaking of birth
great news out of Arizona and this is
one of these delightful sort of
political stories not only in the effect
it has on policy but just in the way it
came about
Arizona outlawed abortion
Arizona didn't Outlaw abortion after
Dobbs or even
right before Dobbs Arizona outlawed
abortion in 1864.
now his law on the books
and then
there were a bunch of challenges to it
in the years right before Roe v Wade and
then it was overturned it was called
unconstitutional for whatever reason and
then it was sort of reinstated and then
you get the Roe v Wade decision which
says there's a national right to
abortion somewhere in the invisible text
of the Constitution and so the 1864
abortion ban in Arizona Goes On Ice
but now Roe v Wade is not the law of the
land Planned Parenthood V Casey not the
law of the land and a judge
the Arizona Superior Court Judge Kelly
Johnson is just ruled
that Arizona's near total abortion ban
which goes back to 1864 can take effect
really good stuff obviously it should
the libs we're going to try to figure
out some way to undermine the will of
the people right this is a
democratically passed law
and some people are going to say well
yeah but it's democratically passed but
it was passed back in 1864.
right that's true laws don't need to be
passed again and again and again every
single year that's not what democracy is
in fact
democracy and practice
involves not just the people that are
walking around today but a much broader
group of people it includes even the
Democracy of the Dead to use
chesterton's phrase that's how a
political order
uh remain stable and grows over time
and this was a democratic law and the
libs wanted to suppress the will of the
people and it didn't work this is really
great news it's great news because it
will at least for now severely limit the
number of abortions in Arizona which is
awesome and which most people certainly
will get on board with
more importantly than that though
it is a reminder that
pro-life the pro-life movement and
perspective
is really really deep in the American
tradition what the libs have tried to
argue is that all abortion it was not
really a big deal and no one even
thought about this and when they did
they favored abortion abortion is
totally fine it's just these radical new
Republicans starting I don't know around
the 1960s or 70s that's when they really
came after abortion and that's just not
true that is just not true going all the
way back not just to 1864 but actually
if you go back to the time before the
the American Revolution if you go to
blackstone's commentaries even which is
so important to English common law which
we heavily rely on here in the American
legal tradition
our our political tradition our
ancestors considered babies in the womb
to be human beings
okay there's a strong argument that the
14th Amendment actually Outlaws abortion
at a national level
certainly in the Civil Rights Acts
passed just after the Civil War you see
this the American tradition is pro-life
the radicals who pretend otherwise who
pretend that there's some constitutional
right to an abortion or whatever they're
making it up out of whole cloth and the
people who want abortion on demand
without apology until a moment of birth
it's not the majority of people it's a
distinct minority of people in terms of
people who want just abortion access
whenever it's something like six percent
of the American people it's it's nobody
okay 94 of Americans oppose that
doesn't matter they got their way for 50
years
brings us right back to what we're
talking to at the top of the show
conservatives we can mock this we can
complain we can say it's not fair we can
say it's so wrong yeah sure we should
learn from that too
political movements that are effective
are always a minority of people
a a dedicated devoted focused courageous
minority that's who gets things done
I mean just even think about our sacred
democracy in our sacred democracy only
half the country votes anyway half the
country votes and then half of that half
votes for one party and half of that
half votes for the other party so even
when we're talking about the broadest
level of American politics we're only
really talking about a quarter of the
country doing anything electing a
president or whatever
and when we're talking about these
specific kinds of movements the sexual
Revolution obviously abortion activism
the drag queen Story Hour Insanity we're
talking about a really small sliver of
Americans who are getting things done
because they have the political will to
do it well why don't conservatives take
a lesson from that because we don't we
don't want to do anything
because the conservatives are still
stuck on a bunch of silly platitudes
from the last 20 years well I don't want
the government involved I don't well
then what are you running for office for
if you're not going to wield the
government to do good things in a just
way within the confines of the law and
the Constitution then I don't want you
in office I just think that actually if
you elect me I'm not going to do
anything okay then go away that's fine
go join Liz Cheney and the other losers
I want a conservative who's actually
going to do stuff
not arbitrarily not capriciously
but who's actually going to go in
and and follow the justice and truth and
the American political tradition to
restore this country to make America
great again that's what I want okay
so that's so much to ask
I don't think it is
speaking of the abortion issue think
about how our opponents are wielding the
state
so Joe Biden sends these Jack booted
thugs in to attack the pro-lifer and now
the FBI is denying it sort of the
headline is
FBI denies sending a SWAT team to arrest
pro-life activist Mark Houck
now listen to how this is being reported
this is even in Breitbart so breitbart's
giving at least the context the full
story but this is how it's being
reported in the mainstream media the FBI
has denied sending a SWAT team of 25 to
30 agents to arrest Mark Houck okay so
what what happened then
well what happened is
in a statement to Fox News a spokesman
with the FBI Philadelphia field office
denied that the SWAT team had been used
quote there are inaccurate claims being
made regarding to the arrest of Mark
Houck no SWAT team or SWAT operators
were involved
FBI agents knocked on Mr houck's front
door identified themselves as FBI agents
and asked him to exit the residence he
did so and was taken into custody
without incident pursuant to the
indictment
but the FBI did not deny that 25 to 30
armed agents were on the scene and
armored agents were on the scene did not
deny that houck's children saw the
Ancients Point rifles at their father
and mother to arrest him
and do not deny that they then threw him
in the back of a car and took him away
so that they're
they're admitting that all this stuff
happened the only thing they're denying
is that it wasn't a SWAT team
no no this is being completely
misreported in the conservative media no
it was we sent some of our nicest agents
there
weren't the sort of special agents
they're just regular agents pointing
rifles at this man and his wife well his
seven kids are looking on in Terror
showing up 25-30 agents at his door
tossing them in the back of the car why
because he thinks that maybe we
shouldn't kill so many babies every year
because he peacefully
protested outside of an abortion clinic
that's why and their denial is oh no
come on now we didn't send the exact
category of Agents you think we sent
they did all the stuff that you're
alleging but you know it was a different
it was a different division
fake news 25 pinocchios give me a break
and they're doing how are they getting
away with this this would have been
unimaginable
unimaginable in America at least for me
maybe it was a failure of imagination on
my part I didn't think that there were
so many evil people in our government
doing such evil things maybe that was my
own naivetevete but now I know
now I know this stuff is not popular
this would not play in Peoria it doesn't
matter they're doing it anyway they got
the power and they're willing to use it
are we willing to win some political
power back or more importantly are we
willing to flex that political power
when we win it I hope so otherwise I
guess we don't deserve to win because
what we're hearing you're seeing this
huge movement of violence from the left
and then the libs the same Libs who are
inflicting the violence they go on TV
and they say gosh you know those
trumpers they're so violent John
heileman an MSNBC just came out he said
these Trump supporters they're going to
take up arms against the Democrats
one in 2020 uh Donald Trump got more
votes in 2020 they got in 2016. uh by by
a lot Millions more votes right um he's
still got whomped by Joe Biden in the
popular vote and yet he came within a
few thousand votes because of our
electoral college system in three states
of winning Electoral College Victory
there's lots of ways that Donald Trump
as he did in 2016 as he came close doing
in 2020 can become president without
winning a popular vote uh majority
that's one thing and I think that's very
much in his head he's been told over and
over again by strategists that that is
the path for him not he can't win a but
he couldn't in 2016 he couldn't in 2020
and he won't in 2024 win a majority vote
he asked us three straight he had to
thread the needle and string together
those 270 electoral votes and be a
minority uh president number one number
two I don't think he cares about he
wants he wants to he knows that this the
core the the path for him forward is
always about division anger energy the
division divided in the country reducing
the Corb is base down but at the same
time making that like into a sauce of a
Kind right it's like he reduces the
doubt it gets stronger more virulent
more toxic more energized also more
violent does Trump think about the is he
trying to necessarily Stoke violence or
he does not care so this is really
important to the first point that he
makes he says Trump never won the
popular vote right because the
presidency is not decided by the popular
vote
if the presidency were decided by the
popular vote I bet you Trump would have
won it
he didn't win it because his campaign
strategy like like all sensible campaign
strategies is going to focus on the the
Battleground States so Trump doesn't
campaign in California he doesn't
campaign in New York
no Republicans do that would be a waste
of time that's not how you win the game
but if you won the if you won the
presidency based on popular vote you'd
see massive rallies in California
massive rallies in New York you would
see the votes shift I bet you he would
win the popular vote but it's a moot
point that's not how the presidency has
decided to this guy's second point
do you see Republicans getting violent I
don't
I see Democrats running over 18 year old
conservatives for being conservative I
see major Democrat politicians calling
for violence against Republicans I see
the president of the United States
calling half the country fascist and
saying we're an existential threat to
the country that's what I see and I see
leftists burning the country down for
eight months at a time with the with the
rhetorical and financial support of the
Dems of leading Democrats that's what I
see
okay and so I don't buy any of this crap
this is
the same kind of tactics that you would
see from dangerous radical political
minorities throughout history from the
Bolsheviks from the Jacobins to all of
it the libs are doing that okay and
they're doing it pretty successfully
maybe it's because conservatives were
outraged we mock them sometimes we
complain about it we shout maybe we need
to learn all right maybe we need to open
up our ears a little bit and take a look
at their successful tactics and then
apply them not in the unjust way immoral
way that they are doing but apply the
same principles in a moral and just way
you know the rest of the show is
continuing now you do not want to miss
it we are going to be joined by my
friend
the great David Limbaugh if you are not
a member click the link in the
description and join us we'll see you
over there
[Music]
[Music]